il est temps qu'on fasse nos bagages et
qu'on laisse notre trace dans ce monde
liberté des hommes au sol
[Applaudissements]
ces imbéciles sont retournés dans le
monde suture à c'est moi qu'on reproche
de faire de mauvais choix
le monde souterrain
cet endroit est le plus dangereux au
monde
admin tu pourrais répéter j'avais une
guimauve coincés dans leurs règles vous
êtes fatigué qu'est ce qui vous amène
sur mon territoire on est revenu ici
pour vivre une vie sans voiture
or comme toi
commence à me demander si c'est possible
c'est sûr que c'est le moment pour se
poser la question
les contrevenants
la seule capitale tu peux nous en dire
un peu plus sur ton équipe de super
héros ce qui me concerne je n'emploie
pas le terme super héros
mais je ne vous interdis pas de
l'utiliser
[Musique]
j'adore les retrouvailles pas mieux